thomas drach er die ist der entführer
des millionenerben jan philipp reemtsma
er wird als haupttäter in diesen raub
fällen betrachtet thomas drach wollte
damals mit der entführung von rihms mal
seinen traum von einem leben in luxus
und den reichtum erfüllen mit einer tat
die 32 tage andauerte in dieser zeit
lebte reemtsma in einem kellerverlies ja
statt seinen traum zu erfüllen gab es
mehrere jahre haft
von dem lösegeld übrigens 15 millionen d
mark und 12,5 millionen schweizer
franken blieb nichts übrig ging drauf
für die flucht von drach für kriminelle
helfer für anwälte und auch spezialisten
haben für reemtsma lösegeld verstecke
aufgespürt das opfer für immer
traumatisiert verarbeitete seine
erlebnisse in dem buch im keller 2013
kommt drach frei ist pleite lebt in der
region deutsch niederländisches
grenzgebiet thomas drach der
mittlerweile 60-jährige ist ein
schwerkrimineller aus dem rheinland
bereits mit 13 wurde er das erste mal
von der polizei aufgegriffen weil er
autos geknackt hatte mit 18 währinger
zusammen mit seinem bruder zwei
überfälle für die er mehrere jahre im
gefängnis saß 1996 dann erlangte tracht
zweifelhaften ruhm weil er für einen der
spektakulärsten kriminalfälle
deutschlands verantwortlich war der
entführung von tabak erbe jan philipp
reemtsma mit drei komplizen entführte
drach den publizisten auf dessen
grundstück und hielten ihn 33 tage lang
in einem keller gefangen
nach der übergabe von 30 millionen mark
lösegeld wurde reemtsma dann mit den
worten sie erleben die luxusversion
einer entführung frei gelassen drach
flüchtete nach südamerika wo er zwei
jahre später gefasst wurde
seit 2013 ist der 60 jährige nun auf
freiem fuß seitdem sollen drei schwere
überfälle auf sein konto gehen und
sprechen wir wieder mit frank schneider
und weiter
zugeschaltet frage wo befindet sich
drach denn jetzt in der obhut der
polizei wird er dann ausgeliefert an
deutschland ja also nach unseren
informationen sitzt der in amsterdam in
polizeigewahrsam
der haftbefehl der muss eben noch mal
verkündet werden es geht ja natürlich
auch jetzt darum wie und wann kann er
ausgeliefert werden nach deutschland die
deutschen behörden also das amtsgericht
köln hat diesen haftbefehle erlassen
und wenn er keinen einspruch dagegen
erhebt dann kann das sehr schnell gehen
in wenigen tagen sollte er längst
beschwerde dagegen einlegen dann kann es
sich um monate dauern bis thomas traf
wirklich nach deutschland ausgeliefert
werden kann der zugriff hatte morgens
mit spezialeinheiten erfolgt zielfahnder
haben ihn monatelang im visier gehabt
er ist aber nicht dort festgenommen
worden inhaltlich vermutete er hat
keinen festen wohnsitz in holland in
deutschland übrigens mittlerweile auch
nicht mehr
er muss sich dort regelrecht im
untergrund bewegt haben was mit den
erbeuteten millionen natürlich möglich
war und die spezialeinheiten haben dann
heute morgen eine große statue
aufgesprengt in einem gebäude wo er sich
aufgehalten hat haben ihn ja völlig ohne
gegenwehr überwältigen können
er war völlig überrascht er hat wohl
überhaupt nicht damit gerechnet und er
sitzt jetzt wohl in amsterdam im
polizeipräsidium in gewahrsam und wie es
dann morgen mit ihm genau weitergeht wie
lange es dauert bis er ausgeliefert wird
das wird sich dann danach entscheiden
was er bzw einen anwalt sein verteidiger
machen werden ich gehe persönlich davon
aus dass er sich nicht erst mal
ausliefern lässt sondern erstmal
beschwerde dagegen einlegt und da muss
man abwarten wie lange es dauert bis er
schließlich nach deutschland kommt und
wie lange es dann auch noch dauern wird
bis sie dann hier der prozess gemacht
werden kann
ganz herzlich willkommen bei b thomas
drach ist das ja sozusagen der
pathologisch böse wie er im buche steht
wie würden sie ihn charakterisieren und
logisch wäre wenn es regelrecht
krankhaft wäre bei thomas drach das
könnte man allerdings erst nach nach
eingehenden diagnostik mit sicherheit
beurteilen was man aber mit sicherheit
sagen kann ist dass er ein sehr
schneller berufsverbrecher ist der im
grunde genommen nichts anderes gelernt
hat er schon sehr früh angefangen hat
seine kriminelle energie umzusetzen
er hat die erfahrung gemacht dass er
eben mit solchen brutalen taten mit
einem sehr geringen aufwand an groß
möglichen nutzen hat das heißt er wird
geleitet von einer unglaublichen
kriminellen energie er einen hohen
planungs grad
und er hat eine sehr niedrige
hemmschwelle wie wir gesehen haben denn
er schreckt auch nicht davor zurück hier
von der schusswaffe gebrauch zu machen
und den kauf zu nehmen dass menschen
verletzt oder sogar getötet
wie geht so einer jetzt damit um dass er
geschnappt wurden äste von der polizei
die ermittlungsbehörden sind ja sicher
daran interessiert auch die mittäter zu
fassen vielleicht hintermänner gehhilfen
zuschnappen spricht so jemand oder
machte er komplett zu ein täter wieder
hat auch so antisoziale persönlichkeit
anteile das heißt also so für das man
psychopathische anteile das heißt er
weiß ja genau was er macht in seinem
tiefsten innern weiß er auch und wusste
er immer dass er früher oder später mal
gefasst wird auch wieder in dem moment
man zugriff über was weiß er irgendwann
bekommen sie nicht aber er bietet nicht
sofort anfangen zu reden sondern er
fühlt sich im grunde genommen sehr
überlegen wie alle jahre weil das teil
seines kindle berufsbildes ist er ist im
grunde genommen herr über leben und tod
er hat die kontrolle er spielt katz und
maus hören sie endlich auch mit der
polizei und der justiz also kontrolle
spielte eine große rolle psychologisch
auch die ausübung von macht ist ganz
wichtig die kontrolle zu haben
wir haben gehört dass er schon sehr früh
im alter von 13 jahren mit drei taten
begonnen hat und häufig sind das junge
täter
die kranke starke emotionale bindung in
ihren familien erlebt haben die handeln
nach einer art inneren drehbuch wenn ich
schon nicht geliebt werde dann will ich
wenigstens gas werden und das mit der
gleichen intensität und er hat gesehen
dass er mit dem geringen aufwand hier
einen raub zu begehen menschen zu
erfahren zu entführen
im grunde genommen seinen
lebensunterhalt bestreiten kann dass er
es dort sehr hohe raub summe erbeutet
hat und das ist für ihn im grund
genommen ja auch krankhaft aber sein
berufsbild
lassen sie uns noch ein wenig über
sozusagen das miteinander in diesen
kriminellen kreisen sprechen
wie würden sie das einschätzen dass im
miteinander und das umgehen von drach
mit seinen mittätern ist er da der kopf
die führungspersönlichkeit und die
anderen empfangen befehle oder ist das
tatsächlich ein miteinander man versucht
im team kriminell zu agieren
solche täter haben natürlich einen
tatplan es geht um das verhalten vor der
parte wie wenig das opfer aus wie
aguirre ich während der tat und wie es
dann auch das nachtatverhalten und da
scheint es tatsächlich so zu sagen dass
drach nicht nur damals bei reemtsma
sondern möglicherweise auch an den
anderen tagen eben der führende kopf
gewesen ist und die anderen dann die
klassischen mittäter gewesen sind das
heißt er dominiert das ganze und in
solchen kreisen ist es dann letztendlich
natürlich egal es immer auf seinen
eigenen persönlichen vorteil bedacht und
würde dann auch mit komplizen über die
klinge springen lassen
es gibt sicherlich auch durch unter den
kriminellen einer gewissen komik dass
dann die beute geteilt wird aber wenn es
darum geht hier weiter unentdeckt sogar
flüchten zu können denkt jeder täter
sowie traf auch mal an sich und sagen
dass im vorteil
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren